The year was the 1990s, and somewhere in the quiet corners of academia, an anthropologist named Robin Dunbar made a discovery that would later become the foundation for a particularly ruthless philosophy.
He found that human brains have a hard limit about 150 people.
That's it. No more. No less.
Beyond that number, relationships fray, trust weakens, and the delicate fabric of social connection begins to unravel.
Now, most people would look at that number and think of community.
A village, if you will.
A network of people who lean on one another in hard times, who return favors without ledgers, who forgive the small slights that life inevitably throws their way.
But we? We see something else entirely.
We see a ledger.
Not the kind with ink and parchment, but something far more insidious, a mental tally of every unpaid debt, every favor left unreturned.
Every moment of perceived imbalance.
This is what we call the social ledger.
And if you're clever, if you're patient, you can use it to dismantle every relationship in your life until you stand alone, untouchable, the sovereign of nothing.
The first step is simple.
You must become an accountant of misery.
Most people live in a world where social grace is the default.
They forget who bought the last coffee.
They overlook the fact that they carried the entire group project on their shoulders while someone else took the credit.
They let small offenses slip, buried beneath the weight of goodwill.
But that?
That is a catastrophic failure of bookkeeping.
If you want your world to be a place of friction, not comfort, you must adopt what we call resentment accounting.
The process begins with memory.
Not just any memory the kind that lingers, sharp and precise, like a needle in your mind.
Every time a friend is late.
Every time a partner forgets to take out the trash.
Every time a colleague steals your idea and passes it off as their own you recorded.
Not in the moment.
Oh no.
That would be too obvious.
You save it, you let it ferment.
You wait for the perfect opportunity, the peak of an argument, the height of emotional tension, and then you strike.
This is what we call peak-end engineering.
The first part of the story is just setup.
The payoff?
That's where the real damage happens.
But memory alone isn't enough.
You must also turn every interaction into a transaction.
Need a cup of sugar from your neighbor?
Don't just hand it over.
Calculate the market value of the sugar.
Factor in the labor cost of your time.
Make them feel the weight of the exchange.
The moment you remove the grease of reciprocity, the moment you turn every act of kindness into a debt, you've already won.
Because now, every favor is a ledger entry.
And every ledger entry is a potential weapon.
And then there's trust.
Or rather, the absence of it.
You must approach every relationship as if it were a game of the prisoner's dilemma.
Always assume the other person will betray you.
So you betray them first.
You ghost.
You cancel.
You spread that little rumor.
Just enough to make them question whether they can trust you at all.
By being the first to defect, you protect yourself.
But you'll also burn the village down around you.
Because trust, once broken, is a fire that doesn't just consume the relationship it consumes everything else, too.
Finally, there's the matter of Dunbar's number itself.
Most people try to expand their circle to welcome more people into their lives.
But you?
You do the opposite.
You keep your number low not by being selective, but by being unbearable.
You apply the broken window theory in reverse.
The moment someone enters your orbit, you let them see the cracks.
A forgotten birthday.
A half-hearted apology.
A single instance of disrespect left unrepaired.
And just like that, they'll start to wonder if they even belong there in the first place.
Before long, your village will shrink to nothing.
And you?
You'll be left standing in the ruins, the undisputed king of a world with no one in it.
The goal, after all, is simple.
Social autonomy.
No debts owed.
No debts to collect.
Just you, standing alone, untethered from the weight of obligation.
A debt forgiven is a connection maintained.
But a debt recorded?
That's a bridge ready to be burned.
And when the last one is gone?
Well, that's when you truly begin to reign.